from Engadget Twitter confirms it
intends to close deal with Elon Musk
Twitter has again agreed to let Elon
Musk buy the company they say the
agreement follows months of legal drama
after musk tried to back out of his
original agreement to buy the company
for 44 billion dollars this spring the
two sides were set to go to trial later
this month as Twitter attempted to force
Moss to keep up his end of the agreement
musk had claims Twitter had misled him
about the number of bots on the platform
and had raised concerns about issues
disclosed by the company's former head
of security who fell The Whistleblower
complaint
so Twitter investor relations tweets
Twitter issued this statement about
today's news we have received a letter
from the musk parties which they have
filed with the SEC the intention of the
company is to close the transaction at
54 and 20 cents per share the question
why did Elon Musk try backing out
go into this big legal drama and then
abruptly just agree to the original sale
price I mean my my attitude was couldn't
he have at least tried to to lower the
price like oh okay we're going to go to
core it's gonna be a waste of time how
about we do 50 bucks per share call it a
day they Pro Twitter would probably have
been like okay fine just well if you
agree to that then we're gonna get an
approval from the show and then we're
done instead he just comes out yeah it's
good just full thing whatever why what's
what's going on here was it because he
was embarrassed by the leaked text
messages or what
uh I I'm an optimist I think he wanted
to expose the Bots
um and why why back out why why yeah
well there's a number of theories the
corporate media is running with a theory
that he was hiding from disclosure that
already the text messages that were
released were allegedly embarrassing and
that he didn't want more disclosure
that's one of the theories that's out
there by the corporate media that
they're taunting counting is the truth
uh but but I think personally I think a
lot of it had to do with the spat that
he had with the Ukrainian president
especially with him trying to offer some
kind of negotiation or peace deal bring
that conversation to the Forefront where
he was dogpiled by the NPCs and by the
corporate establishment that of course
punished him and and and tried to make
him seem like a bad guy because he was
trying to prevent a nuclear war so that
to me was just absurge to see that kind
of conversation unfold with zelinski's
advisor literally sending out a photo of
him photoshopped as a Ukrainian Trader
that's crazy in handcuffs but I mean
come on Luke guys you agree with me
right there's too many people you know
nuclear war would be a good thing just
too many
this is another thing to understand here
around the the Elon Musk Ukraine
controversy because Elon Musk provided
Ukraine with starlink which a lot of
military analysts and experts are saying
is one of the reasons why ukrainians are
having such major victories inside of
this larger proxy war between Russia
because of the GPS satellite tracking
the Weapons Systems all depend on the
internet and the Google CEO Eric Schmidt
former Google CEO who's also working on
the Pentagon lead defense Innovation
board came out and said that Elon Musk
is the true hero when it comes to the
war in Ukraine so to have the Ukrainian
president who has to have his advisors
to have the Ukrainian people lash out at
him and punish him when he already
contributed so much to the Ukrainian
people for this conflict is is really
something that I think might have hurt
Elon Musk and might have added to this
larger decision for him to buy Twitter
since of course he was was painted as
the boogeyman as the bad guy for trying
to prevent a nuclear war yeah diplomacy
nowadays so rare that they frame it as
treason
yeah I mean look I'm really happy about
Elon Musk buying Twitter finally I think
I've been waiting for this for a long
time
um but you know he is kind of the bad
guy because I've lost like 2 500
followers within the past day so he has
some explaining to do I don't know why a
lot of us I think here and Spike Cohen
um the VP candidate for the libertarian
party in 2020 tweeted out that he had
lost 2 000 followers too so I don't know
what the theory is for why that's
happening perhaps Twitter's cleaning up
all the Bots and and hiding that so that
when uh Elon Musk takes control I gotta
look under the hood and I got two
conspiracy theories for you one is
anti-elon one is pro Elon all right
we'll start with the anti-elon one first
Elon Musk announces he wants to buy
Twitter because he really does he says
I'm gonna buy it at 54 a share he then
tries to back out and plays this big
game which ultimately saw Twitter stock
drop down into like the mid 30s or
something like this
one of the things we heard with this
deal Elon is going to some of the other
investors like that that uh there was
that that Saudi Prince I think and he's
telling them use like vote to let this
go private keep your shares I'm gonna
I'm gonna buy up as you know as much as
I can and then you can keep yours if you
agree to take the company private
because I'm going to fix it and then
when it goes public again your stocks
are going to be worth way way more
so the idea is he doesn't need to buy
every single share from every single
person if he can work out these
agreements with the big investors so the
stock price drops 35 a bunch of people
hearing the news is going to do this
start buying up stock at the cheap price
thinking oh maybe I'll get a chance to
hold on to this when it goes private
because you know then once it goes
public again I'll make a bunch of money
and Elon then basically knows if a ton
of people buy at the low rate agree with
them and take it private
he doesn't need to buy their shares it's
going to save him a ton of money now I
don't know if that if that if that's
possible if it makes sense uh I was
talking to Will Chamberlain about he
says he says no I was talking to him in
the context of he does this his buddies
buy up from people at 35 bucks then you
know knowing they're not going to have
to sell to Elon that them holding it
basically allows them to take it private
and he said it's a really bad time to
try and do any kind of financial
malfeasance because you're under such
scrutiny but maybe maybe that's why I
said conspiracy theory here's the other
one Elon Musk was talking about Bots
Luke pointed this out he was saying you
know hey vote on this should Ukraine
offer up some kind of peace agreement he
was saying that um there's people of
Ukraine vote but notice in the U.N
should oversee the Don bass region
elections and then Crimea should be
returned to Russia as it's you know it's
been for a long time and then the
Ukrainian started attacking him he gets
dogpiled the originally the poll says
yes let's have peace but then all sudden
it flips to no no peace no agreement
Elon says the Bots came out in force for
this one I'm wondering if that was it I
mean look this he he was he's been
playing games this this lawsuit for a
long time he if he was really concerned
with the lawsuit wouldn't he have just
conceded a long time ago so I'm
wondering if he saw this and he got
really really pissed off at a bunch of
bots voting to say yes to potentially
nuclear World War III and he was like
I'm buying it and he's gonna go in
because Bots are what he's been
complaining about for the longest time
and he's just gonna just wipe the Slate
on all these Bots and then he's gonna
bring Donald Trump back
do you think Donald Trump will hurt or
help the stock price oh he'll help it
he'll help it yeah he was their bread
and butter before when he had an account
yeah but I don't think Trump would do it
I don't think Trump will come back no
because it'll be social but it's not
just that it's like don't they have dwac
or whatever Trump World acquisition Corp
like you know Digital World acquisition
Corp or something like that well Trump
also made a public statement saying I
don't want to be back on Twitter I won't
be back on Twitter even if Elon Musk
buys Twitter he said this a couple
months ago I don't know if his opinion
changed especially with you know all the
presidential races I I think you know we
understand the importance of of big Tech
social media so those Elon Musk and
there was a couple of things leading up
to this before the whole spite between
Ukraine and Elon Musk he sent out a meme
a couple days ago that said those who
don't study history or doomed to repeat
it yet those who do study history are
doomed to stand by helplessly while
everyone else repeats it so oh man him
after posting that Meme came up with a
proposition to bring peace to Ukraine it
wasn't a perfect proposition but at
least the conversation started there
hasn't been a conversation on peace
deals there have been a lot of peace
deals offered that were very close to
being achieved especially one by turkey
especially one that the ukrainians and
Russians agreed to Western Powers said
no Western media is saying no peace and
their strategy here isn't really a smart
one it's let's let's push Putin into a
corner that's phase one phase two phase
three we don't know what that is yet but
let's just let's just escalate the
situation and it's mind-boggling it's so
crazy that that out of everything that's
happening right now hey we have a
situation that is bringing us on the
brink of nuclear war hey let's repeat
those same policies and double down on
them it is exactly the Underpants Gnomes
where they have the the one like we're
gonna do this and then the next line is
the question marks and then the final
line is profit yeah step one still still
Underpants step two question marks step
three profits exactly that's one so I I
was you know I was thinking about this
with um you know nuclear war and how
they're really really advocating for
this conflict they really don't want any
kind of settlement Arrangement and I was
thinking also about you know
depopulation conspiracies and things
like that and you know what I I like to
say is the only difference between
what's actually happening in a
conspiracy theory is the conspiracy
theory implies intent if you remove the
the hypothesis of intent from an
individual you no longer have a
conspiracy theory you have literally
what's happening so for example what's
going on with everything on the left
telling Farmers how to farm is a food
shortage sterilizing kids aborting kids
um advocating War whether they if you
want to say it's because they intend to
reduce the population okay that's a
conspiracy theory if you say I don't
know why they're doing it but the end
result is the reduction of population
well that's literally what's happening
so I thought about something interesting
I have a series of tweets that I tweet
frequently where I just you know I I say
some I tweet things that I kind of feel
are like they should be cancelable
things like like I tweeted several times
have you considered spaying and
neutering your kids to prevent
overpopulation and I've tweeted things
like the the upside to abortion is that
there's too many children and we need
less people on the planet like these
should be things that ever like anyone
ever said seriously people should be
like whoa whoa whoa come on but there's
not not only does it break no rules on
Twitter to ask people to like consider
sterilizing their children there's no
outrage from the media at all I was
thinking about this I was like I bet if
I tweet things like war is good because
there's too many people they will they
will completely ignore it if I tweet
it's great that children are being
sterilized they'll completely lo and
behold the media doesn't care one bit
there's no smears no cancellation I just
I don't know what their intent is but
for whatever reason everything is
pointing in One Direction these actions
will result in much less people
have you ever been suspended for
anything like that or any of the tweets
removed
have you ever been suspended from
Twitter or I've been locked out
um when they banned the the groomer
stuff they retroactively enforce it
against me and so I had to delete the
tweet and I'm like I don't care about
Twitter like people are like leave your
messages up I'm like dude it's Twitter
I'll just say something else weird I
don't know so I just took him down
that's whatever you gotta misspell it
that's the trick ah yeah yeah writing
code so you can just keep changing the
word it's like Grovers yep exactly so
like taking a step back I mean Elon Musk
started this whole conversation about
acquiring Twitter because he said it was
so important it's the public sphere we
have to have great
um discussion it's it's how we uphold
democracy
um why not why not buy the whole school
system and uh put you know have a better
investment because we have millions of
kids going to government schools where
they're being indoctrinated to think
like socialists when they grow up and I
think that's even more detrimental to
society than the public sphere when it
comes to Twitter the thing is the public
school system is way too expensive Elon
no no I mean imagine where you could buy
with 44 billion dollars how many
politicians could you get in your ladder
how many of them can you have barking
and jumping up and down when you tell
them to jump I think all of them you
have enough money you could have done
that but but I think he also understands
that that big Tech social media is is a
power that is even beyond the US
government when it comes to flexing its
ability to influence society and you
could even see through the disclosures
through the text messages that were
received him saying quote he wants to
reign in big Tech these are the words of
Elon Musk from the text messages that
were released he's saying quote our
Public Square needs not to have
arbitrary sketch censorship and that
quote we have right now what we have
right now is hidden corruption thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and be become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there